CENTER ICE. OVER, THIS SEASON.
A BIG SHOCK, RIGHT IN ERE'S A B
ANXIOUSNESS AND I THINK THERE
IS SOME TENDERNESS ON  ONE
GEICO TO MILWAUKEE, THE
AMERICAN HOCKEY LEAGUE, HE LONG
HE SAYS IT ALL, THERE IS A UY
QUICK SHOT.
FOR THE YOUNGSTER. ILE,
BREAK IN AND OFF THE BACK ENDS.
WE WILL SEND IS WHAT I HAD,
THERE'S A LONG SHOT REBOUND.
WHO SAYS IN HIS 70 SEASON HERE
COMES MINNESOTA'S OTHER UP
TOP, THERE IS A LONG SHOT FOR
PE IS A UNRESTRICTED FREE  FORC
SAME.
BACK UP TOP, NOW IT IS A CROSS.
ONCE AGAIN, A QUICK BACKEND
SHOT. ian: DOES GET THIS TO LON
THE SHOT
THE HIGH SLOT.
COULD YOU GET THE SHOT, WRITE A
OFFENSIVE INSTINCTS.
ANOTHER REAL QUALITY SAY.
THEN YOU SEE SHOT OFF.
AS A GOES TO  TH
COLORS, SO FAR. HIM
OUT
HE HAS THE STEP AND SENDS IT
BACK WITH
GET AND STRENGTH AND SIZE
ON THE STICK OF YELLOW HE TURNS
IT INTO THE ZONE AND DROPS AGAI
REALLY
>> SEVERAL GOOD OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE DOCKS ON THIS SCORES.